merci salut
hé
Tashi Duncan elle va transformer toute une
famille en millionnaires
si j'avais une ligne de mode une
fondation
[Musique]
tu étais crédible aujourd'hui merci je veux dire
ce n'était même pas comme le tennis c'était un
jeu complètement différent
hé viens sortir  avec nous plus tard, laisse-moi
venir te border non, laisse-moi continuer à
parler non allez, à
quelle fréquence cela arrive-t-il de s'en prendre à
la même fille pas aussi souvent que tu le
penses, nous avons habituellement des types différents, donc
tu dis que je devrais être flatté
n'êtes-vous pas du genre à tout le monde
[Musique]
lequel d'entre nous
il n'est pas amoureux de toi qu'est-ce qui
te fait penser que je veux que quelqu'un
soit amoureux de moi c'est agréable de voir
s'éclairer sur quelque chose même si c'est ma
petite amie
[Musique  ]
Art a son entraîneur Tashi Donaldson qui
est aussi sa femme Je joue pour
nous deux Tashi
Je pense que nous sommes peut-être dérangés par le
fait qu'elle aurait pu être dans un salon
comme moi quand nous étions adolescents quand nous
étions adolescents hé  Je t'aime, je
sais que
tu ne sais pas ce qu'est le tennis, c'est
une relation, nous sommes
allés dans un endroit vraiment magnifique
ensemble,
je prends tellement soin de mes petits
garçons blancs,
je suppose que tu as planifié ceci, pas cette partie.